so hello to all that we are
introducing my name is damien scaglia game
professor at the free university of
brussels specialist in
international criminal law and specialist in
international crimes
I would first like to thank
hama and liliane who have
Sunday nicely  invited to participate
brings to your seminar
today we are going to make a
rather theoretical and rather
short presentation of the two issues in the matter
with regard mainly and that
is what I was
called for or what we have on
invited me here with regard
mainly to the floods of the
French army or the crimes of France
as in Algeria we see that these crimes
are of two orders first of all
war crimes or crimes against humanity
we will see since  the qualification is
important committed before
decolonization that is to say before 1962
and then crimes committed also after 62
since we are also going to be
interested today in
nuclear tests  French workers in the
Sahara who started before
62 and who sell 60 mehdi
ended after 1962 I will come back to this
in a few moments the objective of
this short presentation is
going to be to give an overview of the actions
that have been  carried out about these
events events which marked and
which still mark the relations between
between france and algeria which
marked the domination of france
over algeria the colonization of france
on
colonization by france of algeria
these dramatic events which
today still have medical
repercussions
firstly human on May 6 but
also legal
two types of events I will say
criminal acts and nuclear tests
which I do not qualify here as a crime for
the moment we  we will come back to this since
it is one of the questions that will be asked
for the opening at the end of the course to
the offer with regard to the crimes
had the idea of ​​public notoriety and I
will not return there.  above that during
the events in Algeria as
France says where during the Algerian war
which was qualified as an armed conflict by the
French courts, in
particular during this war acts
of torture murders summary executions
were committed  by
the French army in the 1950s
judge how far the very beginning of the
1960s I will not go back over the facts
themselves
you know them
if ever it could be an exercise to
do for future seminars and
discussion seminars in parallel  to
this was carried out from 1960
nuclear tests and in particular the
first nuclear test which was done in
reggane in the sahara
these tests continued until
1966 that is to say that they began
before independence  algerian but
they continued under an agreement
which were annexed to the evian agreements
of 1962 they continued after
that is to say with the agreement of
newly decol algeria  oniser
that raises a question and we will see it on
the responsibility also of algeria
even if this agreement which has long been
kept secret
to let it be understood let us
imply that
the sahara was not completely
colonized or in  in any case that algeria
did not have full sovereignty
over algeria
these axes these
nuclear tests bomb tests
mainly there were 17 years all of them
and
they were recognized very late
just like the crimes of the army
Algerian were recognized very
late in French law I
will come back to this in a few moments
since I will come back to a law, the
Morin law of 2010, which not only
recognizes them but allows the
victims of these nuclear tests
as well as the victims of
nuclear tests in  French polynesia
thus allows this time less than 2010
for the victims to obtain
reparations of the compensations we will
see it in which 4
before proceeding to a  a little
more in-depth analysis of our subject which will be
divided into three stages, first I will
talk about the crimes themselves and
what has been carried out in particular before the
French courts since the
1980s, then I will address the question
of nuclear tests to  tell you where
we are today and what has
not been done before seeing what are
the possible potential avenues that
will ultimately be an opening on the
next seminars
that I will follow partly
at a distance and in particular by virtue of the
course that I  'we will have at the beginning of October where I
will already answer a series that your
questions will
follow during two of this day
before starting the pardon this reflection 1.3
time it seems important
to me to define two things 1 crimes
against humanity and  of war crimes
why because these crimes
are at the heart of our concerns
regarding the behavior
of France in Algeria and therefore
without even a
quick definition  of these crimes
we will not understand the result then two
things war crimes and
crimes against humanity ness
legally speaking by factually
but legally speaking arise
mainly in any case for
crimes against humanity and are
developed mainly for
crimes  of the war at the time nuremberg
in nuremberg it is the post-
war judgment the judgment which made it possible to
judge twenty senior
nazi officials for war crimes crimes
against humanity and go to crimes
against peace which will become by  the
continuation the crime which is called the crime
of aggression the crime of war and the
girls from this moment and will be it until
2002 with the establishment of the statute of the
international penal court this court
which judges today individuals
allegedly committed war
crimes crimes against humanity or genocide or
crime of aggression
war crimes are defined
as acts that take place during a
conflict  armed bed and therefore it is a fundamental element of
context
during an armed conflict against
protected persons or protected property
who these people are it is
well protected
it is the soldiers who are no
longer fighting because injured because they are
prisoners of war  are the civilians
who cannot be military targets
these are the people
specially to protect the
medical personnel the medical personnel in particular
what the very short definitions that
we would need we could go much
further in this definition even happy
all that will be enough  for our
work crimes against humanity
very important or even more important than
the others are defined in the
nuremberg statute in article 6 as acts
committed
against the civilian population therefore
directly against the civilian population
at the time of nuremberg they were
defined according to  of the context to know too much could
only appear within the framework
of an armed conflict
today  today it is a crime there are
possible or therefore confirm
massive violations of
human rights committed against the
civilian population the text tells us within the framework
of a generalized or systematic attack
which targets the civilian population so we
have something here  important to know is
a definition which appears in 1945 in
the statute of the court of nuremberg and
which will be developed just like the
definition of the crimes against the
war crimes which will be developed until
2002 and until today still
these two small deficits have posed
we are going to see that several
legal or judicial procedures have been
opened have also been closed in relation to
the events that interest us
without their really succeeding
for war crimes and crimes
against humanity in  strictly speaking they
never succeeded for the
war crimes of the french army in algeria
as regards the nuclear tests
they did not succeed but it does not  was
not judicial we fall from it
note that we
will speak here
of the
companies of the procedures which
mainly
targeted people or which bet the
French state but always within
national procedure that is to say that
procedures of the type international court
of  justice of the procedures of
the international committee type or to the Luzians
of human rights not to my knowledge have
not been started or have not succeeded in
any case
and I put aside the
diplomatic procedures which it does not concern
our our court
I do not  in any case not
immediately address the issue of
open or potentially open procedures in
Algeria this will be the subject of your
research I think since
I do not know Algerian law well enough
I do not know much about one
Algerian procedure and so we
can talk about it later so
if you don't mind, let's start first
with the events outside the
nuclear tests
the events the crimes  is by
the French army in Algeria then it
should be known that these events have
never been recognized as being
crimes against humanity
and therefore
nor moreover as war crimes
and therefore they have benefited from a
French amnesty law before the
French courts a
brief historical reminder in
nine without end in the
1960s in 66 and 68 exactly
[Music]
finally pardon 64 France is passing
an amnesty law which provides amnesty for
all offenses committed within the framework
of  France's interventions, particularly
in Algeria,
this law aims for
mercy and a general and absolute amnesty law
and it extends to all
offences,
that is to say that it extends in any case
in French law implicitly
also to  crimes that could be
qualified as war crimes or crimes
against humanity since the 80s
two proceedings, in particular in 86 88 two
proceedings are initiated in france
for crimes committed murder torture p  ar
the French army on Algerian nationals
these procedures and his to make a toro
of all the procedure will lead to two
judgments of November 29,
1988 of the arts is very important and in
particular the judgment on youtube
of the judgments of the criminal chamber of
the  court of cassation which will very
clearly say that 1 the crimes
themselves are not crimes
against humanity
2 that they are therefore potentially
common law crimes but that these
common law crimes are
covered by an amnesty which is
invested with  the law of
1964 it is very astonishing as the ball to
raise in particular stone is for that
or as will raise it
isabelle fouchard moreover it is
very astonishing because the court of
cassation had a very different approach
in a business barbie business which
concerned crimes committed
by klaus barbie during the
second world war
court of cassation which therefore said that the
amnesty law did not apply
to crimes committed by k  laus barbie
since this amnesty law
mainly fell under
the laws of nuremberg as follows
mainly noted that the crimes of the nazis
or associated with the nazis did not come under
the amnesty law, that is to say that
concerning the crimes of the second
world war  the judges of the
french high court set
aside the amnesty law and
in a certain way do not make
the law retroactive in order to be able to judge klaus barbie
I will come back to this feedback
because it is something quite
complicated but only for the  crimes in
algeria the court of cassation has evacuated this
since 1988 the court of cassation
has never
ruled differently it has
had to do with judgments which
concerned crimes committed in indochina in
another former French colony the
boudarel judgment it  has had to deal with other
cases, in particular 1,000 for crimes
committed in Algeria in a case of
May 30, 2000, and it has always gone in
this direction, namely that
[Mus  ique]
the provisions of the law of 1964 which
make crimes
against humanity imprescriptible
do not apply to crimes
committed in algeria or elsewhere except for
crimes committed by the nazis or in connection
with the second world war so he
says to  imprescriptibility, that is to say
that
crimes committed by the Nazis or in
connection with the Second World War can be prosecuted at vitam aeternam
but not other
crimes elsewhere and it clearly states this
in
the 2000 judgment
elsewhere
it considers that the principles
of equality of non-retroactivity
precludes the new penal code
of 1994 from
applying before its entry into force
it should be noted that this new penal code
specifically incriminates crimes
against humanity in the  French law,
that is to say that before 1994 there was
no
incrimination in French law for crimes
against humanity and that is why it
will consider this court that Algerian crimes are
nt common law crimes
and therefore that they can be
amnestied by the law of the 1960s
moreover it will consider dancing in these
same arenas as international law
international custom
does not allow these crimes to be qualified as
crimes against humanity  since they
cannot be qualified in
national law as well to see international law
does not apply
either that is what the court tells us
is otherwise well as there are not
two qualification of crime
against humanity the facts are prescribed by
the law of
1962 sorry not 1964 1962
the issue we see here is the very
definition of the criminalization of
crimes against humanity, that is to say that
until 1994  French law
does not recognize crimes against humanity
with the exception of crimes committed
during the Second World War by
a lacquer this evening by the Germans and
the Italians in particular
the Court of Cassation therefore refuses to
qualify the Algerian crimes as c  rhymes
against humanity and therefore applies
the amnesty law of 60.2 to him and does
not apply the credibility crisis to him does not
apply to him the qualification of crime
against humanity
it is something strange why
finally the  strange it can be explained
politically legally she could
have arrived at a completely different
result, that is to say a she could have
said that the definition that there was
in zero is the opposite of the one I
spoke to you about earlier at  the introduction
applied to crimes committed in
algeria it applied why
because the statute of nuremberg had
imposed a jurisdiction for the court
which stopped at war but
do not impose a definition of crimes
against humanity which  stopped at the
crimes committed by the Germans that's
a first thing she could have
come to that with another conclusion
secondly she tells us the court of
cassation that the crimes being defined in
94 they cannot apply before
gold in the art and barbie that i told you
about earlier it is quite
clear that the court is applying
pre 94 crimes against humanity because
the art is one
they date from before 94.2  it applies
to acts committed in 44
and that therefore it could have done
this retroactivity it could have
done it in particular on the basis and that leads
to the third argument on international custom,
namely to say ok the
French law does not  may not have applied,
but by virtue of international custom
there was well after 45 the existence of
crimes against humanity or
war crimes which
correspond to the acts committed by
the French army in Algeria so we have
here very clearly  a
very strict interpretation of the principle of equality
interpretation which is
fair to a certain extent but
which could have led to something else even
if in my opinion on this point the Court of
Cassation has its reasons
and in particular in view of the latest
case law of the  court  European Union
of Human Rights with which France
must
also
comply on the question of
the amnesty that the court takes for granted
with the law of 1962
it is clear that if in 60 of this
amnesty could apply to these
crimes  today we know very well,
in particular under
international law and international
criminal law, that the mli ch'ti
is not acceptable or in any case for
international crimes and therefore we have
seen very clearly appear for
about twenty years now  in
the case law of the European Court
of Human Rights in the
case law of the Inter-American Court
case law
of international criminal courts the
rejection of amnesty and therefore
the French high court could have
accepted that this  amnesty is not
valid it raises a question of the
retroactivity
of the amnesty note but it is here I
refer you to the previous argument to
say that this argument  ent could have been
evacuated also quite quickly
here for the crimes committed in algeria
and the quillan treatment which was
made of them by the french courts
young 11 years old if you want our
second point knowing the
nuclear tests then for the nuclear tests
to see therefore  they started in 1960 that as
early as 1959 there was a resolution of
the general assembly of the united nations
resolution
42 80 which asked france not
to carry out these nuclear tests
france expressly refused to
comply with this resolution
on the pretext that the  English
American and Russian arsenal were such
that it was necessary to protect oneself and to
protect oneself it was necessary to carry out
nuclear tests to create this
nuclear bomb moreover France maintained
at the time an argument to say that the
radioactive fallout would not be
important one  saw the result
of the cancers of the diseases of the dead
thereafter but it will be necessary to remember one
thing is that at the time  there was
no treaty prohibiting these
nuclear tests nor was there any
custom prohibiting these
nuclear tests certainly certain
doctrines considered that these nuclear tests
are a violation of the convention which
represses the genocide convention of 1948
have well  of the international covenant for
civil and political rights which was
being drafted at the time this seems to me
rather unrealistic
a question which has not been asked her
toes felt that these nuclear tests
are crimes against humanity
florine think about she s  is not posed
like that but I think that we
could support it have four tried to
support it
note nevertheless that if there was no
criminal procedure in the strict sense of the term
there was an acknowledgment of these
tests  nuclear tests and the repercussions
of these nuclear tests on the
victims
this recognition took place and its
repercussions this recognition of the
repercussions took place by a law the
morin law  of 2010 and this law allows
the victims of the french nuclear tests
in the evening of algeria or in
french polynesia the victims to
seek compensation
this law allows to seek compensation
with something quite interesting
it is first of all it reverses the proof of
the causality the law clearly says that
if people prove that they are
sick and that it was present in
the vicinity of the nuclear tests
carried out by France already in the Sahara
then the victims can have access
to reparations so it is not  a
criminal conviction these are
mainly financial reparations
but the law says so within a very strict framework,
namely that there must be
specific illnesses these illnesses
are the following they are listed
in a decree decree 2014
1049 which follows  the morin law of
2010 and it is leukemia but not
chronic lymphocytic leukemia
since the doctors considered that they
were not
radiation-induced it  that is to say that they
were not the result of
radioactivity myelodysplasia cancers of the breast
of the thyroid body for exposure
during the period of growth
as frank skin cancers but
not malignant melanomas
lung cancers cancers of the  colon cancers
of the salivary glands etc etc I
refer you to the text of decree 2014 1049,
that is to say that for these diseases there
is a reversal of causality if
there are not these diseases there if there is  it
's about other diseases and a priori to other
diseases that were induced by
there exposure to radiation then
there is no presumption of causality
what beat me there is going to be reparation
because she will say that  'we have to prove the
link which is complicated since the law
was there to precisely frame this
causality
what is even more complicated is
that if the French military
veterans could be compensated because they
had papers when he was well
close  ente on the spot because there
are army records the
local civilian populations they find it difficult to
prove it and as they find it difficult to
like it well there is
no compensation we only know  a single
case of a local civilian woman who
was compensated
for the death of her husband a few
decades later
but this is the only case this is the only case
and it is quite special we
can talk about it again if you want  a little
later,
therefore, reparations if we manage to
prove that we were present
in the case of specific diseases,
but nothing more
here, with regard to nuclear tests
, are some lines of thought
we will discuss again during the course and
questions and answers  from the
beginning of October
first of all a question of qualification,
we must now
try not to qualify the crimes,
therefore the first part
of the events we talked about because these
are crimes against humanity without meaning
without risk even if the  neck  r of cassation
to evacuate that but we must ask ourselves the
question of whether nuclear tests
are or can be
qualified as crimes against humanity and
for that we must take up the statute of
the international criminal court gives the
law in force today  today to see
if we can qualify this as a crime
against humanity,
note that even if we couldn't do it, that does
not mean, given
the arguments of the Court of Cassation,
that we could argue this before
French courts but  in any
case it would already be a point
of crimes against humanity perhaps
of war crimes
why because since nuremberg
war crimes against the environment
have been developed have been incriminated and
one could wonder if nuclear tests
in  sahara are not
crimes against the environment so there
is also something to be done there is here
to dig a little
bit moreover we have to rework we
have to research we have to do
research  hes on this question of
the imprescriptibility
why because this
imprescriptibility
is questionable
is questionable because
if we manage to qualify the
different crimes the crime
against humanity a priori we should be able to
say that these crimes are
imprescriptible which would mean
that if at the time
of their acts they were already provided for
by international law, which was
the case, it should not be possible to
prescribe, then criminally speaking, we have
seen that but there is not much on the
other hand, we could wonder whether before
international or
national bodies and I will come to that it
might not be
worth reworking this question
of imprescriptibility
finally
[Music]
and that is more important we have to think
about several procedures
first of all for what they are  trial
for the purposes which there are the procedures in
France apart from the question of
whether they have reparations still it is necessary to
find the evidence in relation to the
nuclear tests we have little chance
of succeeding
so the procedures in France should
mainly focus one on
nuclear tests by qualifying them as a
crime against humanity and that I believe
that it has not been searched enough two
see procedures  of
civil reparation by the Algerian victims by
providing proof that it was still
present
at the national level another
possible procedure and there it is a
search
that must be done that you must make
these rights in fact if it  it is not
possible to file a complaint brought before
the
Algerian
civil judge the events the cases the crimes
the nuclear tests namely to file a
complaint against the French state but
before the Algerian courts
against French nationals is not
I don't know Algerian law I
don't know Algerian procedures
but since the French can judge
by universal jurisdiction or
by other links of attachment of
foreigners on its territory 3 algeria
could not go ahead if they take
into account other
problems political problems
diplomatic problems but legally it
would perhaps be worth it and then
internationally it is clear that the
international criminal courts the international criminal court
are not
bodies that have jurisdiction so I
have not spoken about it I exclude them on the other hand one
could wonder if a
before the European court of human
rights  man, there wouldn't be anything
to do for nuclear tests as
for international crimes,
but for that you
have to review the court's case law a little bit
and then perhaps in a
much more way
- less aggressive perhaps but
perhaps more diplomatically tried
to also go
before the human rights committee
and for these jurisdictions there for its
instances there it could be
interesting to do procedures and
I r  Come back to my precedent in Algeria to
say that they do not succeed because
they will surely not succeed and
it is before the UN committee
I suggest that you keep this in mind
we will talk about it again in a few days
or a few weeks depending on whether  we will see
on video thank you for your
attention and I will see you very soon